how many cups are in three and a half
gallons so before even addressing this
question let's just think about how
large a cup is and actually i'll give
you a little bit of overview of how many
cups there are in a pint how many pints
in a quart and how many quarts in a
gallon so let me just draw a little let
me draw a cube here and let's imagine
that this is a gallon
let's imagine this is a gallon
the most
common time we see a gallon is when you
see a gallon of milk so let's say that
that whole thing is a gallon you can
imagine if it had a handle it'd be kind
of a big gallon of milk now there are
four quarts per gallon there are let me
write this over here there are four
there are four quarts
four quarts per gallon so if i were to
draw the quartz here i could divide this
gallon into four quarts
and then each of these sections would be
a quart so
you have four quarts four quarts so this
right here that i've just drawn in blue
would be exactly that would be
one
one quart and obviously there's four of
them in this entire gallon now you can
divide the quartz into pints you have
two
two pints
two pints per quart
two pints per quart so this quart that i
drew here i can divide it into two
i can divide it into two like that and
this little section that i'm
highlighting in magenta is a pint
that is a pint
right over there and then finally there
are two cups per pint
there are
two
two cups
two cups per
pint so this pint right here i can
divide it into two and each of these
will be a cup so this section right here
right here
will
be a cup now we could go straight and
figure out exactly how many cups there
are per gallon actually that might be an
interesting way to think about it
if you have four quarts let's multiply
it right here so you have four quarts
per gallon
so you have four
quarts
four quarts per gallon
times two pints per quart
times
two pints
two pints per quart
what does this give you this gives you
four times two is equal to
eight
and then the quarts cancel out and you
have eight pints eight pints per gallon
eight pints
per gallon and that makes complete sense
because we had four quarts in this
gallon and then each of those quarts
have two pints in them so four times two
so eight pints per gallon and then we
can multiply that times two cups per
pint which i could just copy and paste
this right here so let me just copy and
paste this
copy and
paste
actually i should have cut and paste
so let me select it again
i want to do that so i get that real
estate back so edit cut edit paste there
you go so now you multiply this times
two cups per pint
and the reason why this will work is
because you have a pints in the
numerator cancels out with a pint in the
denominator and you will be left with
you will be left with i'll go back to
the yellow eight times two is sixteen
in the numerator we have cups
cups per
gallon now we just figured how many cups
are up or down that makes sense this
section right here
is about is exactly 1 16 of this entire
cube this entire gallon but we haven't
even answered our question we want to
figure out how many cups there are in
three and a half gallons so let's write
it over here so we're concerned with
three and one-half gallons i don't like
working with mixed numbers i like to
turn them into improper fractions three
and a half is the same thing as two
times three is six plus one is seven
this is the same thing as seven over two
if you divided 7 by 2 you would get 3
with a remainder of 1 or this would be 3
and a half so this is the exact same
thing
so we want to know how many cups are in
7 halves gallons
so what we want to do is end up with
cups and we want the gallons to cancel
out so we have a gallons in the
numerator right here or it's definitely
not in the denominator and so we want to
divide by gallons we want to divide by
gallons and then we're going to have
numerator we have cups
in the numerator and how many cups are
there per gallon well we just figure
that out there are 16
16 cups per gallon when you multiply
these two quantities the gallons will
cancel out and you'll just be left with
cups and that's what we wanted so it's
going to be 7 halves times 16. so this
is going to be 7 times 16 over 2 cups
cups and then 16 divided by 2 or you
could divide 16 by 2 and get 8 2 divided
by 2 is 1 so it just becomes 7 times 8
divided by 1 or just 7 times 8 which is
56 so this is equal to
cups and this should make sense this
should be a much larger number because
cups are much smaller unit so if you
have three and a half gallons you will
have many many many more cups in that
three and a half gallons so this makes
sense